Oh
and of course my macho dad threw a fit
and he started calling the house collect
every day threatening to kill my
stepfather which i think is hilarious
that my poor stepfather had to pay for
his own death threats this is not
happening I'm going with junior we all
come from somewhere
from someone who nurtures us protects us
and teaches us some better than others
[Music]
so this is a story about how I tried to
kill my dad
trust me it's hilarious trust me so you
guys haven't heard the term blood is
thicker than water right I hate it my
dad must have said it to me a thousand
times growing up blood is thicker than
water son blood is thicker than water
son and I just started to hate it
because I think it's what family members
say to you when they do something shitty
and instead of apologizing they're just
like hey we have the same blood type so
you have to put up with this so I
would hear it all the time my dad would
miss like basketball games and
graduation and he'd always say blood is
thicker than water son and he end up
missing most of my childhood cuz when I
was five years old he went away to
college well that's what my mom called
it you guys could of course call it
maximum-security prison and every couple
years on spring break he would get out
and he would come visit my little
brother and I and luckily my mom
remarried and we had a great stepdad who
taught us how to ride a bike and build a
fire stuff that you're supposed to learn
from your dad because when my dad would
come to town he would teach me the stuff
he knew about so for instance my dad
taught me three things in life I'll
never forget
number one you never snitch no matter
what number two if you have extra food
at lunchtime you only give it to white
people weird the teleforce grader I
agree and the craziest one of all my dad
got out on spring break one year and he
came back home to visit us and he took
me and my little brother swimming we had
a great day at the pool jumping off the
diving board playing Marco Polo and I
got out of the pool and I'm in the
locker room and I'm taking a shower and
my father comes in and he sees me shower
and he's like hold on son get out of the
shower for a sec I was like why what's
up dad he goes son every time you take a
shower from now on before you get in the
shower put the water on as cold as it
can go and then get in that cold water
and shadow box until you count to 15 I
was like dad why would I do that
and he's like son the way your body
reacts when that cold water hits it is
the same it'll react if you ever get
stabbed so if you ever get stabbed
you'll be able to fight for 15 seconds
so my dad so my dad tells the 12
year old I'm like an idiot I'd do that
time like 19 and I get a girlfriend
and she's like why we fake fighting in
this cold shower like you better be
ready bitch you could go down anytime
this was real so that's my dad so
my dad only did one good thing for me in
life of course I had a wonderful stepdad
and before I was about to start junior
high he set me in my little brother down
and he said he wanted to adopt us and
have us take his last name like we were
his sons and of course my macho dad
threw a fit and he started calling the
house collect every day threatening to
kill my stepfather which i think is
hilarious that my poor stepfather had to
pay for his own death threats
[Applause]
but he would call and he would remind
his blood to stick into water you're my
son and uh he eventually sent some goons
over the house to like scare my stepdad
and my mom made a decision like forget
it let's just keep your last name which
is the only good thing that my father
ever did for me because if my stepdad
would have adopted me I would have
started junior high school as Brandt
Huff and dick which I think has got to
be the shittiest last name in the world
my poor little sister's named Haley -
dick I don't know why she didn't get
married at midnight on her 18th birthday
but she didn't do it so that was my dad
and then after that he disappeared for
like eight years and I never heard from
him and I went to real college in
Phoenix well junior college so kind of
real but I went but then one day I got a
letter out of nowhere and it was from my
dad and he just said I'll be at the
Phoenix Airport in three days and I'd
love to see you there's no time to write
back just I'll be looking for you I
didn't know what to do because I was
doing so good in life and I hadn't seen
him in almost a decade
but then partners like I got to go see
my dad so I went to the airport which is
one of the weirdest moments in my life
because this was before 9/11 so you
could go from gate to gate and when I
got the airport I realized I didn't even
know what my own dad looked like so I'm
in looking in the bars and bookstores
I'm like is that my dad is that my dad
and then of course I saw a guy with a
ponytail of wife-beater brown khaki
pants I'm like there's my dad so I run
over I give him a hug and we both fight
back tears and he tells me how much he
missed me and how blood is thicker than
water and he's determined to be part of
my life again and he said I'm moving to
Vegas I have this incredible cocktail
waitress girlfriend and you're allowed
you know you can come see us whenever
you want and I was like okay dad thanks
I got to go back to college and I drove
back to my dorm and when I got to my
dorm I called my two best friends back
in Wyoming who also had shitty dads
growing up and I told him this story and
they're like we should go see your dad
on our spring break and I was like all
right cool
so they drove down from Wyoming they
pick me up in Phoenix and we went to
Vegas on our spring break and spent five
days with my dad which was incredible
because we were just dumb kids from
Wyoming he taught us about like hookers
and craps
seafood buffets we're like holy
this is incredible
so at the end of the five days he's like
you guys are welcome to come back
whenever you want you can live with me
and my girlfriend in this trailer and we
were like sorry dad we got to go back to
college and they start driving me
towards Phoenix and every mile we got
away from Vegas we were just itching to
get back and by the time we got to
Phoenix the three of us idiots made the
decision that we were gonna drop out of
college and move back to Vegas to get
our dream jobs as pirates at the
Treasure Island we thought what would be
better than wearing an eyepatch and
jumping off a big ship every hour while
drunk tourist chicks scream at us we're
like that's it that's the dream job so
we dropped out of college our families
are furious with us and we moved to
Vegas and of course we don't get pirate
jobs I don't we didn't know anything
about casting or any of that and so
my friend sober up and they they go back
home to Wyoming and re-enroll in college
but I was enjoying hanging out with my
dad and I didn't want to leave so I
decided to stay and then one day I
actually got the dream job I would go
play basketball every afternoon with a
bunch of professional gamblers and one
of them hired me to be a runner so my
job was just to carry hundreds of
thousands of dollars worth of cash up
and down the strip and bet on sports so
it was great I was making a ton of money
everything was good so I told my dad
we're moving out of this trailer and I
rented this beautiful house on a golf
course I start calling my little brother
who lived in Portland at the time just a
little stoner dude that ran a subway and
I told him you got to come to Vegas it's
me you and dad we can finally be a
perfect little family again and he's
like alright and he moved to Vegas and
we had a great time the first six months
we'd sit on the back porch every night
just get drunk tell stories he'd tell us
about prison riots and and we'd
tell him about scoring eight points in
the JV basketball game or whatever
shitty stories we had he obviously had
much better stories but he was always
just waiting to get off parole he's like
I can't wait to get off parole I can be
my own man again and he'd talk about it
every day and we counted down the days
till he finally got off parole and I
remember I threw a big party at the
house invited all our family and friends
over and we just got wasted and I
remember about 4:00 in the morning it's
just me and my dad and brother in the
kitchen
and we're just telling them how proud we
are and we're just drunk and it's just
this incredible moment and then but that
is the last good moment I'll ever have
with my dad because the next morning he
woke up got back on drugs started
bringing around like little
twenty-year-old meth heads to my house
even though they're younger than me my
dad's like 48 at the time he starts just
acting like a drug addict you know
stealing my friends wallets forgetting
my birthday just being a shitty dad and
I knew it was going bad but I didn't
know how to get out of it and as you
know it's hard to yell at your own dad
and I knew it I knew it was gonna happen
and then on a Saturday during football
season I'd have to bet college football
all day so I get to the strip at 8:00 in
the morning I'd run up and down and bet
to like nine o'clock at night and I'd go
home go to bed and then do the same
thing for NFL on Sundays so on this
Saturday I worked my ass off I come home
I'm exhausted when I get home my dad's
there all cracked out and I tell him hey
Dad I'm going to bed you can come down
tomorrow and get everything comped if
you want to watch football he's like
okay son and I went to sleep about ten
o'clock around midnight my little
brother busts in and he's like hey Brant
Brant someone stole my money my little
brother had saved up three hundred and
fifty dollars to fly to Portland to
watch his girlfriend graduate college so
I jump out of bed like the big brother
and I run downstairs to try to find my
dad and tell him to find whatever little
shitty kid took my brother's money so
when I get downstairs I don't see him
and I'm yelling for him and I go look in
the garage because my white trash dad
had this stupid convertible Camaro that
he thought was like the dopest car in
the world and it always had to be parked
in the garage so when I got in the
garage and I looked and his Camaro was
gone it hit me oh I got all my
money upstairs and I ran upstairs and my
dad had stole $80,000 cash from me and
now I've worked for guys that you don't
want to be $80,000 short for office not
that there's any job you could be
$80,000 short for
but I'll never forget that and I see my
little brother crying and I'm like you
stole eighty thousand why would you go
steal your own sons three hundred fifty
dollars you know and it it just drove me
crazy and to watch my little brother cry
you know I brought him from Portland he
was doing good and I brought him into
this so in that moment I made the
decision I'm like that's it I'm gonna
kill my dad I'm gonna
kill my dad so the next morning I wake
up and I call my cousin Kato who lives
in Phoenix and he's like perfect he's
like a real gangster and the most loyal
dude in my life and I tell him what
happens he says I'll be there in five
hours
[Laughter]
he drives straight from Phoenix to Vegas
and when he gets there doorbell rings I
opened the door and there he is he's
like where's he at where's he at as I
hold on I got a plan now in my defense I
was 23 years old I've never killed
anybody before this is before Dexter
Breaking Bad this is obviously a
stupid plan but this was my plan my mom
had told me a story that when when I was
young my dad had cheated on my mom and
got chlamydia and he had to go the
doctor and the doctor prescribed in
penicillin not knowing that he was
deathly allergic to penicillin so he
took that penicillin and he almost died
so in my head I was like that's it
you know almost every morning my dad
would go to the Jamba Juice like three
blocks from my house get a Jamba Juice I
mean that was like his favorite thing so
Isis figured it if I just get some
penicillin put it in a Jamba Juice give
it to my dad he'll drink it he'll be
dead
perfect airtight plan so I tell my
cousin he's like all right I mean I can
get penicillin so it's like he's like
well you can get anything trust me
so he's like alright I go one more part
of this plan everyone will think like
I'm the number-one suspect so I'm gonna
go to Colorado and you guys just take
care of this they're like alright
you're kind of a but we'll do it I
don't want to go to college like my dad
so I fly to Colorado you know I mean my
girlfriend goodness's Park we go go to a
hotel and I called my cousin Cato I'm
like yo are you ready he's like we're
ready extra-large mango in the fridge
just waiting for your dad to come home I
was like all right cool call me when
he's dead he's like so I waited about an
hour two hours no phone call I call him
back I'm like yo what happened like well
your dad came home but he wouldn't take
it I was like what do you mean he
wouldn't take it like we gave him the
Jamba Juice but he just put it back on
the kitchen counter I was like and
looking back I get it
you know my dad was in Leavenworth and
real prison so he knows you don't take
like a gift from your enemy you know I
don't think he thought we were trying to
kill him but he probably thought we
pissed in it or something stupid right
so I said you know what forget it this
plans stupid just go with the original
plan pack up my brother's stuff go to
Phoenix I'll fly home we'll just never
talk to my dad again
my cousin's like nah that we do it
my way now I'm like what's your way he's
like we do it my way we'll call you in
an hour
and he hung up the phone and I just sat
there in that hotel like what are they
gonna do and this is the plan they came
up with so they knew my dad loved that
stupid Camaro and it always had to be
parked in the garage so what they did
was they opened the garage door and then
they went out and they cut the phone
lines and the power lines and they just
waited for my dad to come home in this
dark corner in the garage sure enough my
dad came home just like they thought
parked in the garage
hit the button to get the garage door to
shut it wouldn't shut they said he was
so frustrated he didn't know was going
on and he got out of the car went over
got the garage door manually shut it and
locked it and as soon as he locked it
and started to walk back through the
garage into the house my brother and
cousin jumped out with golf clubs and
tried to kill him in the garage with
golf clubs but they were idiots
because there was no light
so they're swinging their hearts out
almost killing each other it's like we
needed a better murder caddy they
it all up
but there was there was only the only
light coming into the garage was there
was a side door that led to the backyard
and at the bottom of that side door
there was a little doggie door and
there's a little light coming through
and my dad saw that light and he just
put his shoulder down and ran and bust
through that door and fell into the
backyard jumped over the back wall onto
the golf course and ran away and that
was like 17 years ago and I've never saw
him or spoke to him since that day so my
brother and cousin go to Phoenix three
days later I fly back from Colorado and
I'll never forget I was standing in the
garage with this garden hose trying to
clean up the mess they made and that's
when it hit me I was like my dad was
right this whole time his blood is way
thicker than water
[Applause]